On écoute Emmanuel Macron qui est en direct
à Mulhouse en Alsace
Dans cette région Grand Est.
Dans cette région qui est à ce jour.
la plus touchée par l'épidémie de Covid-19
et l'une des premières frappées en France
Il y a près d'un mois.
dans le Grand Est
plusieurs centaines de nos compatriotes
ont perdu la vie
plus de 700 se trouvent
en état grave
placés
en réanimation.
Je m'associe à la douleur des familles.
etdes  proches
Je vais leur dire que la nation toute entière est à leurs côtés.
Je veux aussi ce soir.
saluer
la mémoire des soignants
qui ont payé
de leur vie
leur engagement
pour soigner d'autres vies, sauver d'autres vies.
Depuis le début de cette épidémie
le premier soignant
est tombé, il y a quelques jours à Compiègne.
Trois soignants ont perdu la vie dans la région Grand Est.
Ils avaient décidé de soigner, coûte que coûte.
Un gynécologue obstétricien ici à Mulhouse, un médecin généraliste
dans la commune
de l'hôpital en Moselle
un médecin généraliste à Colmar
une ville
très durement touchée
Nos pensées accompagnent leur famille.
Leurs proches.
Toute les communauté des soignants.
Mes chers compatriotes
Je vous ai dit il y a quelques jours que nous étions engagés
dans une guerre
une guerre contre un ennemi invisible
ce virus
le Covid-19.
Et cette ville, ce territoire.
porte les morsures
de celui-ci.
lorsqu'on engage une guerre
on s'y engage tout entier
on s'y mobilise
dans l'unité.
Je vois dans notre pays
les facteurs de division
les doutes
toutes celles et ceux qui voudraient
aujourd'hui fracturer le pays alors que
nous ne devons avoir qu'une obsession :
être unis
pour combattre le virus.
Et j'en appelle à cette unité, à cet engagement.
Etre unis,
et vous avez un gouvernement qui l'est,
à la tâche, œuvrant
pour trouver les solutions et se battant.
Le ministre de la Santé reviendra dans les prochains jours comme il l'a déjà fait.
Et comme il le fait constamment sur les sujets les plus sensibles en toute transparence
le sujet des masques, des respirateur,
des tests, des traitements, pour apporter toutes les explications
toutes les demandes d'information légitime.
Mais sans que nous ne cédions
à aucune forme de division sans que jamais nous ne cédions
au flot de fausses informations.
Nous n'avons qu'une priorité
battre le virus.
La nation toute entière est mobilisée.
Mobilisation d'abord des services de l'État
qui est totale
ici dans le Grand Est
depuis le début.
Sur le plan sanitaire d'abord, tout est mise en œuvre.
pour que le service,
nos services de santé, puissent
faire face à la vague
L'Agence Régionale de Santé à lancé très tôt
Un appel au volontariat des personnels soignants
plus de 1000 engagés ont répondu présent dans la région, dont 250 ici à Mulhouse.
Une organisation s'est mise en œuvre
consistant à déprogrammer les opérations qui n'étaient pas urgentes
pour libérer des lits, mobilisant le secteur privé
faisant jouer tout la solidarité entre l'hôpital le secteur privé
les respirateurs sont arrivés d'autres hôpitaux
les armées
Un déploiement complet a été fait. Nous avons ici dans cette région
mis en place une organisation
une méthode
inédite
qui sera répliquée partout
où elle sera utile.
Solidarité aussi nationale qui joue à plein
Plusieurs transferts ont été organisés vers des régions moins touchées.
Une trentaine de patients et ainsi été conduits dans d'autres hôpitaux
de la région
Trois opérations menées par les armées ont permis de transférer 18 patients
vers d'autres régions et demain un train médicalisé
sera affrété pour transférer une vingtaine de patients, à nouveau.
La mobilisation
de nos systèmes de santé et totale
Je veux saluer tous les personnels de l'hôpital
les hôpitaux de la région
mais aussi
tous les médecins de ville
que j'ai croisé tout à l'heure et avec qui j'ai pu discuter.
Et l'ensemble du secteur
sanitaire
médico-social et social.
Mobilisation aussi de tous les services de l'État
Je veux saluer les préfets qui
au côté des responsables sanitaires
sont mobilisés
pour assurer la continuité des services publics.
Tous les services de l'État sont mobilisés.
Nos policiers
nos gendarmes, douaniers, l'ensemble de nos fonctionnaires.
Nos enseignants, à qui aussi je veux dire merci car ils continuent
de s'occuper de notre jeunesse
de manière physique
pour les enfants de notre personnel soignant
mais de tous les autres aussi
sans relâche.
Je veux ici aussi remercier
l'ensemble des collectivités locales la région le département l'agglomération et la ville
et l'ensemble de leur personnel qui n'ont cessé
d'être également au front.
Enfin
Je veux remercier
nos voisins allemands, suisses, luxembourgeois qui ont pris en charge une trentaine de patient lourd comme nous l'avions
comme nous l'avions fait fait il y a quelques semaines.
pour nos voisins italiens.
C'est cela aussi l'Europe la vraie
cette solidarité
Dans cette première région si lourdement touchée
cette mobilisation a été exemplaire.
L'organisation
a permis collectivement de nous améliorer pour apporter
une réponse
indispensable.
Ici, nous avons fait bloc
pour soigner, pour sauver.
c'est en activant tous les leviers de la solidarité et en faisant bloc
que nous pourrons faire face.
En Corse, la situation est déjà très difficile.
Oui demain dans les hauts de France.
en Bourgogne Franche-Comté en Île-de-France
en Outre-Mer
des situations extrêmement tendues
sont en train d'arriver
dans chacun des territoires que je viens d'évoquer
la situation, chaque jour,
est plus difficile et c'est la même organisation qui
se met en place.
Elle se met en place aussi parce qu'une formidable mobilisation nationale
est là et je veux vous en féliciter vous en remercier mes chers compatriotes.
La réserve sanitaire d'abord
avec plus de 40000 inscrits
permet d'apporter des bras, des soutiens à des femmes et des hommes qui se ré-en gagent pour aider.
Plus de 100 000 d'entre vous
se sont engagés sur la plate-forme jeveuxaider.gouv.fr.
pour, là-aussi
à leur manière, avec leurs moyens
apporter une aide
au milieu de cette crise.
C'est cette France fraternelle
qui nous permettra de tenir et de vaincre.
Mais derrière cette organisation
il y a toujours et avant tout les femmes et les hommes.
Je suis ici à Mulhouse à leurs côtés pour leur rendre hommage.
Dans cette guerre
il y a en première ligne
l'ensemble de nos soignants
qui interviennent à l'hôpital en ville
dans les EHPAD
Dans nos établissements accueillant des personnes en situation de handicap, dans les services à domicile
qu'il soient médecins, infirmiers, ambulanciers, pharmaciens, aide-soignants
tous sont en première ligne.
Les yeux sont cernés, la fatigue est présente.
L'angoisse est là pour même pour leurs collègues pour leur famille.
Je l'ai vu aujourd'hui avec beaucoup de force.
La nation tout entière
est derrière eux, reconnaissante.
Elle leur rend hommage
chaque jour.
Elle est à leur côté
à chaque instant
avec un courage exceptionnel
ils font face
ils sauvent des vies
ils font tout ce qui est
en leur pouvoir.
Nous serons là aussi.
au rendez-vous de ce que nous devons
au-delà de cette reconnaissance et du respect.
J'ai demandé au gouvernement
d'apporter une réponse
de court terme
pour l'ensemble des personnels soignants comme pour l'ensemble
des fonctionnaires
mobilisés
afin de majorer les heures supplémentaires effectuées et sous forme d'une prime exceptionnelle
pouvoir accompagner financièrement
cette reconnaissance.
Mais plus largement
nos soignants qui se battent aujourd'hui
pour sauver des vie se sont hier battus
souvent pour sauver l'hôpital
notre médecine.
Beaucoup a été fait, sans doute pas
suffisamment vite, pas suffisamment fort.
L'engagement que je prends ce soir pour eux
et pour la nation toute entière
c'est qu'à l'issue de cette crise
un plan massif d'investissements
et de revalorisation de l'ensemble des carrières
sera construit pour notre hôpital
C'est ce que nous leur devons c'est ce
que nous devons à la nation.
Cette réponse sera profonde et dans la durée.
Je veux aussi saluer l'ensemble des
femmes et des hommes qui sont en
deuxième ligne, qui permettent à nos
soignants de soigner et au pays de
continuer à vivre.
Ce sont les femmes et les hommes qui
transportent, qui hébergent, qui dépannent, qui
nettoient, qui réparent, ce sont nos
agriculteurs ce sont l'ensemble des
femmes et des hommes qui sont dans le
secteur de l'alimentation, des commerces
de première nécessité, ce sont nos
livreurs, nos caissiers et nos caissières,
c'est tout ce peuple travailleur de
France qui se bat qui, je le sais, parfois
est angoissé, souvent pour eux mêmes et
leurs familles, mais permet au pays
de vivre.
Je veux ce soir avec beaucoup de force
les remercier et leur apporter tout le
soutien de la nation.
Je sais les attentes qu'il y a là aussi
pour être mieux protégés et le
gouvernement fera le maximum pour
apporter toutes les réponses avec les
contraintes qui sont les nôtres, toujours
en transparence.
vendredi je rassemblerai l'ensemble des
partenaires sociaux et un très gros
travail a été fait ces derniers jours
pour, secteur par secteur,
apporter les meilleures réponses pour
organiser le travail, pour mieux protéger
au travail
je veux remercier l'ensemble des
employeurs de tous ces secteurs qui ont
beaucoup fait là aussi pour que la
nation continue à vivre, cette deuxième
ligne est indispensable et je veux
remercier tous nos compatriotes qui avec
courage chaque jour
permettent au pays de continuer à vivre
dans ce contexte.
Leur travail, leur engagement leur courage sont aussi notre fierté.
Et il y a la troisième ligne.
Celles et ceux qui peuvent télétravailler
ou rester à la maison
arrêter leur activité pendant un temps
ou qui y sont contraints parce que le secteur d'activité
a fermé et qui contribuent aussi
à l'effort de la nation en restant chez eux
en respectant les règles de
confinement qui ont été édictées par le
gouvernement, en réduisant les contacts
en luttant contre la propagation
du virus.
Je vous remercie mes chers compatriotes
de cette part que vous prenez
à l'effort collectif.
Elle est indispensable pour protéger
notre système de santé, pour ralentir ce
virus et protéger l'ensemble de nos
soignants, nos réanimateurs, permettre de
sauver un maximum de vies, protéger aussi
nos aînés et les plus fragiles.
Chacun a un rôle et dans ce contexte
nos armées ont un rôle et je veux les en
remercier et je terminerai par là.
Nos armées sont déjà mobilisées comme ici à Mulhouse
avec cet hôpital de campagne
dans lequel je viens de me rendre et par la
mobilisation aussi du service de santé
dans son intégralité
cet hôpital a été monté dans des délais
records par le service de santé et
l'armée de terre.
Les cinq hôpitaux d'instruction des armées sont aussi
mobilisés où des malades sont déjà
pris en charge.
Des opérations de transports sanitaires aériens et
maritimes ont déjà été réalisés par les
avions ravitailleurs.
Les opérations Morphée de l'armée de
l'air, le porte-hélicoptère amphibie Tonnerre
d'autres soutiens, d'autres
missions de soutien encore, partout je le sais
nos militaires sont prêts
et déterminés.
Nous sommes en guerre et face à ce qui
se profile, ce pic de l'épidémie qui est
devant nous, j'ai décidé sur proposition
de la ministre des Armées et du chef
d'Etat major des armées de lancer l'opération Résilience.
Cette opération
distincte de l'opération sentinelle qui
continue de se concentrer sur la lutte
contre le terrorisme, quant à elle.
Cette opération résilience
sera entièrement consacrée à l'aide et
au soutien aux populations ainsi qu'à
l'appui aux services publics pour faire
face à l'épidémie de Covid-19 en
métropole et en Outre-Mer, en particulier
dans les domaines sanitaires, logistiques,
et de la protection.
Dans ce cadre j'ai d'ores et déjà décidé
de déployer immédiatement le
porte-hélicoptères amphibie Mistral
dans le sud de l'océan indien.
Et à partir de début avril
le porte-hélicoptère Dixmude ira se
positionner dans la zone Antilles-Guyane
en soutien de nos territoires ultramarins.
Mes chers compatriotes,
Mesdames Messieurs, je reviendrai dans
quelques jours faire un point complet de
la situation, vous dire les décisions
prises pour les semaines à venir et les
décisions plus profondes que j'entends
prendre pour la nation.
Mais ce soir je voulais être là, aux côtés de nos
soignants aux côtés de nos armées
aux côtés de nos malades
pour dire que toute la nation est engagée
engagée dans ce combat.
Chacun a un rôle à jouer.
Chaque citoyen parce que la nation
française est un bloc et parce que dans
cette guerre nous devons faire bloc
être unis fiers et reconnaissants
pour le rôle de chacun et tenir.
L'unité et le courage nous permettront de vaincre.
Nous ne sommes qu'au début, mais nous
tiendrons, nous tiendrons parce que nous
nous ne céderons rien
nous tiendrons parce que nous en avons la force.
Vive la République
et vive la France.
Je vous remercie
Merci à vous
Merci Mesdames Messieurs
Merci à nos armées, merci à nos soignants